Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL, "
JENASCIA'S HEIGHT
BECAME AN ISSUE.
EVERYTHING HAS TO BE BETTER
BECAUSE YOU HAVE LESS HEIGHT.
AND AFTER DRAMATIC
MAKEOVERS...
Shandi: PRETTY.
Tyra: SOME WERE HAPPIER THAN
OTHERS.
Catie: (sobbing)
Tyra: AS THE MODELS DANGLED IN
AN ACTION PHOTO SHOOT,
AN EMOTIONAL CATIE FACED HER
FEARS,
LEAVING XIOMARA STARVED
FOR ATTENTION.
Xiomara: I DIDN'T REALLY
HAVE MUCH DIRECTION
BECAUSE HE WAS COMFORTING CATIE.
Tyra: BUT IT WAS HEATHER WHO
WAS ASKED TO LEAVE.
NINE GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Xiomara: WE WAKE UP, AND
WE'RE SO TIRED BECAUSE
WE ONLY HAD TWO HOURS OF
SLEEP FROM THE NIGHT BEFORE.
I'M THINKING THAT I HAVE TO
ONE-UP EVERYONE ELSE
WITH WHAT I'M DOING BECAUSE ON
THE LAST JUDGING,
THEY TOLD ME THAT WAS MY WEAKEST
WEEK EVER,
AND I WILL NEVER ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN AGAIN, EVER.
Catie: I'VE NEVER BEEN UNDER
THIS MUCH PRESSURE,
AND I ACTUALLY THINK I'M
HANDLING IT VERY WELL.
(sighs)
Jenascia: I'M SHORT,
AND I DON'T CARE.
LOOK HOW SHORT I AM.
THE JUDGES SAY THE SHORT THING'S
GONNA BE A FACTOR.
Janice: 5'7" IS A LITTLE SHORT
TO BE A MODEL,
SO WE HAVE TO COMPENSATE.
Jenascia: AND I'M SHORT!
BUT I HAVE TO OVERCOME THAT AND
DO THE BEST THAT I CAN
IN EVERY SINGLE SITUATION.
Mercedes: RECENTLY
AT THE HOUSE, MY HAIR HAS BEEN
FALLING OUT
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH MEDICATION
I TAKE EVERY DAY.
I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH LUPUS,
WHICH IS A CHRONIC ILLNESS
WHERE IT ATTACKS YOUR
IMMUNE SYSTEM,
ABOUT A YEAR AGO, AND IT PRETTY
MUCH
CHANGED MY LIFE.
IT'S BEST TO KEEP
IT A SECRET,
'CAUSE I DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT, "OH, HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
OH, THIS MUST BE HARD,"
YOU KNOW?
DON'T GIVE ME THAT.
I DON'T NEED IT.
Xiomara: I LOVE BOXING.
I CAN'T WAIT TO GO.
THIS MORNING, WE HAVE TO WORK
OUT WITH MARTIN.
IT'S, LIKE... (deep voice)
"YO, YO, YOU KNOW, WHAT'S UP?
COME TO MY GYM."
(normal voice) IT'S 8:30.
Mercedes: IT'S 8:30?
Xiomara: YES, ON THE DOT.
WE HAVE TO GO DOWNSTAIRS.
CAMILLE, LET'S GO!
Camille: YOU KNOW,
I'VE ALWAYS, LIKE, HELD THE
ELEVATOR FOR EVERYONE.
Yoanna: JUST CLOSE THE DOOR.
Camille: I WAS THERE TWO SECONDS
AFTER
THE ELEVATOR CLOSED.
I WAS, LIKE, IF THEY WANT TO
HUDDLE UP,
YOU KNOW, AND BE FRIENDS AND GET
IN THE ELEVATOR,
GO AHEAD AND DO THAT.
IT'S A COMPETITION.
IT'S NOT A SORORITY.
YOU'RE NOT HERE TO BE FRIENDS
WITH ANYONE.
THE POINT IS TO WIN.
♪♪♪
Martin: (whistling)
ANYTIME YOU'RE READY.
COME ON, KID.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GETTIN' READY.
WE GOT A COMPETITION
NOW, RIGHT?
AND IT'S NOT THE WAITRESS
OF THE YEAR COMPETITION,
IT'S THE TOP MODEL COMPETITION.
WHOEVER'S THE TOUGHEST
MENTALLY, WHO'S EVER THE MOST
FOCUSED,
THAT'S THE ONE THAT WINS, OKAY?
COME ON, LET'S GO.
LET'S GET SOME GLOVES ON.
WE'RE GONNA DO A LITTLE
BOXING TODAY.
YOU GUYS SET? GO.
TRADE PUNCHES. BOTH HANDS.
COME ON, PICK IT UP.
PICK IT UP. PICK IT UP.
HARDER, HARDER, HARDER.
LAST ONE STANDING.
COME ON, LET'S GO.
YOU GOTTA HIT IT
WITH EVERYTHING YOU GOT.
ANYBODY WANNA GO HOME?
Women: NO! NO!
Martin: OKAY.
HIT IT! HIT IT! HIT IT!
Catie: OH!
Martin: YOU QUIT.
YOU'RE OUT. YOU QUIT.
YOU GONNA HIT IT HARDER
THAN THAT?
OUT. KEEP GOING. COME ON.
HIT HARDER! HIT HARDER!
TOO SLOW. GET OUT OF THERE.
COME ON. DONE. YOU'RE OUT.
GET ON THIS SIDE. GET THAT SIDE.
COME ON, BOTH GUYS.
BOTH GUYS, KEEP HITTING!
COME ON, KIDS!
Shandi: THE LAST MAN
STANDING--IT'S DOWN TO APRIL
AND CAMILLE.
Martin: HIT IT! WE GOT TEN
SECONDS, ALL RIGHT?
TEN SECONDS!
Women: APRIL! APRIL!
Martin: EIGHT!
COME ON, PICK IT UP!
PICK IT UP!
Camille: EVERYBODY WAS, LIKE,
"GO, APRIL! GO, APRIL! "
BUT NOBODY WAS SAYING, "GO,
CAMILLE! "
Martin: YOU WANT TO
HIT THE BIG TIME?
YOU WANT TO HIT THE BIG TIME?
THREE, TWO, ONE!
DONE.
Women: (whistling, clapping)
Martin: OKAY. DRAW.
WE'RE GONNA SETTLE
THIS BY PUSH-UPS.
OKAY, SET? GO.
ONE. TWO. THREE.
GOTTA GET DOWN THERE.
FOUR. FIVE.
ALL RIGHT, HOLD
IT RIGHT THERE.
HOLD IT.
COME ON, HANG IN THERE.
HANG IN THERE. HANG IN THERE.
YOU WANNA GO HOME?
HANG IN THERE, COME ON.
KEEP THAT BACK STRAIGHT.
April: I'VE LEARNED IN THE
PAST, "OKAY, THIS BURNS.
THIS HURTS." BUT IF YOU JUST
DEAL WITH THE PAIN,
YOU WILL REAP THE BENEFITS.
Martin: SHE'S WEAKENING.
SHE'S WEAKENING.
Camille: OH!
Martin: YOU GOT IT.
THE WINNER--APRIL!
April: I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THINGS IN LIFE
BY NOT GIVING IN TO WEAKNESS.
Martin: THIS KID
IS FOCUSED.
SHE'S DEDICATED.
YOU GET THE GOLD.
Camille: I REALIZE THAT NOT A
LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE DOWN WITH ME, BUT I'M DOING
THIS FOR ME,
NOT ANYONE ELSE.
Martin: GET OUTTA HERE!
Shandi: "YOUR CLOTHES TELL THE
WORLD
WHO YOU TRULY ARE.
YOU ARE WHAT YOU WEAR.
COME DRESS TO EXPRESS."
Sara: COME DRESS TO EXPRESS?
Shandi: WEAR WHAT
EXPRESSES YOU.
Sara: YEAH!
♪♪♪
Tyra: HEY, EVERYBODY!
Women: HI!
Tyra: HOW YOU DOING?
Women: GOOD.
Tyra: WELL, TODAY YOU GUYS ARE
GOING TO BE LEARNING
ABOUT PERSONAL STYLE, AND I HAVE
MY BUDDY HERE
MR. SIMON DOONAN.
SIMON IS THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
OF BARNEYS NEW YORK,
AND HE IS SINGLE-HANDEDLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING
WINDOW DRESSING
AN ART FORM.
Xiomara: SIMON IS AWESOME.
I WAS SO EXCITED TO SEE HIM.
HE'S LIKE, A FASHION GURU.
Simon: IN NEW YORK, YOU NEVER
KNOW
WHO YOU'RE GOING TO
RUN INTO,
SO YOU HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT HOW YOU DRESS
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
Tyra: YOU HAVE TO KNOW,
"WHAT IS MY
PHILOSOPHY ON LIFE,
AND HOW DO I
EXPRESS THAT
WITH MY CLOTHING?"
THE WINNER OF "AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL"
IS GONNA BE WORKING
THE RED CARPET.
YOU WALK DOWN THAT
RED CARPET.
THERE'S A HUNDRED PHOTOGRAPHERS
TAKING YOUR PICTURE,
AND THAT IMAGE GOES
AROUND THE WORLD.
I'VE BEEN ON
BEST-DRESSED LISTS,
AND I'VE BEEN ON
WORST-DRESSED LISTS,
BUT I THINK
IT'S A LOT
MORE INTERESTING TO
TALK ABOUT WHEN I WAS
ON THE
WORST-DRESSED LISTS,
AND I HAVE SOME
EXAMPLES FOR Y'ALL.
IN TERMS OF
PERSONAL STYLE,
HERE'S ONE WHERE I LOOK
LIKE A DAMN FOOL.
I LOOK LIKE A HO.
YOU KNOW, EVEN THOUGH
I HAVE ON A SKIRT,
WHAT THE HELL--
WHAT THE HELL AM I WEARING A
BIKINI TOP
TO AN AWARDS SHOW FOR?
AND I HAVE THE ULTIMATE
WORST-DRESSED PHOTO
COMING UP RIGHT NOW.
I WAS ASKED TO HOST THE
ACADEMY AWARDS PRE-SHOW.
I HAD LOST MY DAMN MIND.
IT WAS A WEDDING DRESS,
BUT I WAS, LIKE,
"MAKE IT IN PURPLE!"
AND EVERYBODY WAS SAYING--
Simon: GLINDA THE GOOD WITCH.
Tyra: "GLINDA THE GOOD WITCH ."
Simon: LITTLE BO POOP.
Tyra: IT DIDN'T STOP.
WE'RE GONNA KIND OF ANALYZE EACH
AND EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF YOU.
I WANT YOU TO STAND UP AND
EXPLAIN TO ME
HOW YOUR CLOTHES TELL
A STORY ABOUT YOU,
STARTING WITH APRIL.
April: I THINK I'M
MOST COMFORTABLE
IN MY OWN SKIN.
I LIKE TO SHOW A LOT OF SKIN.
Simon: WHEN YOU SAY YOU WANT
TO SHOW A LOT OF SKIN,
THAT ISN'T NECESSARILY A
FASHION POINT OF VIEW,
SO YOU'VE GOTTA CONSTANTLY WEIGH
OUT, "DO I LOOK GROOVY?
DO I LOOK HIP?
DO I LOOK STYLISH?"
VERSUS "DO I JUST LOOK
PROVOCATIVE? "
Tyra: MERCEDES,
EXPLAIN TO ME YOUR
PERSONAL STYLE.
Mercedes: I GREW UP
IN A LATIN COMMUNITY,
SO I ALWAYS WEAR
FRESH FLOWERS IN MY HAIR.
Simon: THAT WOULD
BE MEMORABLE TO ME,
AND AT THE END OF
THE DAY,
THAT'S WHAT YOU GUYS WANT.
Tyra: SARA?
Sara: I LIKE TO BE FUNKY.
I DON'T ALWAYS
LIKE TO MATCH.
Simon: YOU HAVE TO BE REALLY
CAREFUL WITH THE THINGS
THAT YOU TAKE FROM
STREET STYLE.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, SHANDI.
Shandi: I LOVE OLD MOVIES,
SO IF I FIND ANYTHING
THAT LOOKS
KIND OF
VINTAGE TO ME,
I LIKE TO WEAR IT.
Simon: WHEN I SAW YOU, I
THOUGHT, "HERE'S A GIRL
WHO'S GOT HER OWN
THING GOING ON ."
Tyra: SKIRT'S GREAT.
IT JUST--YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE SO COVERED.
SHOW A LITTLE
SOMETHING SOMEWHERE,
LIKE A WIFE BEATER
OR SOMETHING.
ALL RIGHT, XIOMARA.
Simon: THAT'S GOOD,
WITH THE HOOP EARRINGS.
I THINK YOU FIGURED OUT
A LOOK THAT YOU'RE OWNING.
Tyra: I LIKE THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE SOME SEXINESS HERE,
BUT THEN YOU'RE COVERED HERE.
IT'S A NICE BALANCE.
CAMILLE.
Camille: MY PARENTS ARE FROM
JAMAICA, WEST INDIES.
MY PERSONAL STYLE IS NORMALLY
JUST WEARING, LIKE, THE COLORS
OF THE FLAG FROM
THE COUNTRY
THAT I'M FROM.
RED IS FOR THE BLOOD
THAT WAS SHED,
YELLOW IS FOR
THE SUNSHINE
AND GREEN IS FOR THE LAND.
Xiomara: OH, GOD. CAMILLE?
BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
Tyra: I THINK YOU'RE PROBABLY
THINKING ABOUT
THE COLORS
TOO MUCH, AS OPPOSED TO
EXPRESSING YOUR CULTURE
THROUGH
OTHER WAYS.
I'VE SEEN YOU
EXPRESS IT
THROUGH
PUTTING YOUR HAIR UP--
Simon: THIS MIGHT BE A LITTLE
TOO THEORETICAL.
Tyra: YOANNA.
Simon: OF ALL OF THE GIRLS,
I THINK YOU LOOK MOST LIKE
A REGULAR MODEL.
YOU LOOK LIKE
A GROOVY,
HIP FASHION MODEL.
Tyra: JENASCIA?
Jenascia: I THINK THAT
THIS SKIRT MAKES MY LEGS
LOOK A LITTLE BIT LONGER,
WHICH IS IMPORTANT.
Simon: YOU DO SEEM TO HAVE
A SPECIFIC PERSONAL STYLE,
BUT I DON'T THINK
YOU'VE NAILED IT.
Tyra: I'M NOT LOOKING AT YOU
HERE TO BE TALLER.
I'M LOOKING AT YOU
HERE TO REPRESENT 5'7".
CATIE?
Catie: I JUST GOT A BRAND-NEW
HAIRCUT.
I THINK THIS FITS MY NEW--
KINDA JUST TIES
THE WHOLE
HAIRCUT TOGETHER.
Simon: I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE
TOO MUCH HOOKER STYLE
GOING ON WITH THE LEG WARMERS
WITH THE HIGH HEELS.
GO DOWN WHERE THE HOOKERS
HANG OUT BY THE DOCKS
AND SEE WHAT THEY'RE
WEARING, AND THEN AVOID IT.
BUT IT'S-- THE TOP FROM
HERE UP IS FINE.
Catie: OKAY.
Simon: DON'T GET
DISILLUSIONED.
SOMETHING THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE TO BECOME
COMFORTABLE WITH--
BEING SELF-CRITICAL,
BEING CRITICAL OF EACH OTHER,
AND WHAT I GET FROM SOME
OF YOU GUYS IS THAT YOU
CAN'T YET DO THAT,
IN PARTICULAR, YOU.
YOU SEEM TO BE GETTING
KIND OF IRATE BECAUSE--
Catie: YOU CALLED ME
A HO.
Simon: I WOULD NEVER SAY
ANYBODY WAS A HO.
I WOULD SAY,
"THAT'S HO STYLE ."
YOU HAVE TO GET USED TO
THE FACT THAT IT'S
NOT REALLY ABOUT YOU.
Catie: IF IT WAS YOU AND ME
TALKING, THAT'S COOL.
Simon: EXCEPT YOU KNEW
WHEN YOU ENTERED
INTO THIS COMPETITION THAT
YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO SIT THERE FOR THREE WEEKS
WITH AN UMBRELLA DRINK
WITH EVERYBODY TELLING
YOU HOW FABULOUS YOU ARE.
Catie: NO,
I DIDN'T EXPECT THAT
AT ALL, BUT I JUST--
Simon: IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU DID.
Simon: SOMEBODY TO CALL IT--
SAY YOU LOOK LIKE A HO--
Simon: IT WASN'T EVEN
CRITICISM.
IT'S ABOUT STYLE.
Jenascia: THE PERSON THAT TOOK
IT THE WORST WAS CATIE,
AND I'M SITTING NEXT TO HER,
AND I'M JUST
SHOCKED AND AMAZED
THAT SHE'S BACK-TALKING!
Mercedes: SHE'S AN
ACTRESS.
SHE'S SO GOOD AT ACTING.
SHE'S, LIKE, "OH,
I'M UPSET.
PLEASE, PLEASE LET EVERYBODY
KNOW I'M UPSET ."
YOU HAVE TO TREAT
HER LIKE A BABY.
Sara: I FEEL LIKE TYRA
KNOWS WHAT'S GOING ON,
AND SHE KNOWS WHO CAN
TAKE IT AND WHO CAN'T.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: MY WHOLE FEAR OF
HAVING LUPUS IS THAT
PEOPLE ARE GONNA JUDGE ME, THINK
I'M NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO DO THE WORK.
IT'S, LIKE, "OH, I CAN'T HIRE
YOU BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE GONNA
BE TOO TIRED.
YOU'RE GONNA BE
SLEEPING ON THE JOB ."
I WANT TO PUSH AS HARD
AS I CAN TO GET THIS.
"GET READY FOR
A WACKY DAY
WITH THE WILDEST
DESIGNER
IN NEW YORK CITY!"
Camille: THE TYRA MAIL SAYS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO MEET
ONE OF NEW YORK'S
WACKIEST DESIGNERS.
Women: WHOO!
Camille: YES!
Betsey: HI! HELLO!
Women: OH! WHOO!
Betsey: I'M BETSEY.
Shandi: FIRST THING I SEE IS
BETSEY JOHNSON,
AND I JUST FREAK OUT,
LIKE, YAY!
Betsey: PERSONAL
STYLE IS,
UM, TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHO YOU
ARE, AND BEING THAT.
THAT AIN'T EASY.
MY NAME AND MY STYLE HAS
HAPPENED SIMPLY BECAUSE
I'VE WORKED HARD,
AND I STUCK TO WHO I AM
AND WHAT I LOOK LIKE.
NOW HERE'S A PERSONAL
STATEMENT.
I HOPE YOU ALL CAN SEE MY LAST
SHOW, BECAUSE THAT SHOWS
A VERY SPECIFIC
KIND OF GIRL.
LET'S GO SEE
SECONDS OF IT.
YOU SHOULD SEE HER AT THE END.
SHE DANCES THE WHOLE WAY, AND
THAT'S WHAT I WANT
MY NEXT SHOW TO BE LIKE.
I WANT ALL THE GIRLS TO DANCE IT
UP A BIT,
NOT JUST GIVE ME
THIS FABULOUS WALK.
AND BOOM. THAT'S GREAT.
SEE, FOR MY SHOW,
THAT'S WHAT I WANT.
WHOO! CARTWHEEL TIME.
YOW!
WHOO!
NOW THAT YOU'VE
SEEN MY STYLE,
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
THE APARTMENT,
AND YOU'RE GONNA BE
PUT TO THE TEST
TO SHOW ME
YOUR STYLE.
SO NOW THE REAL
TEST IS ON.
♪♪♪
Betsey: NOW IS THE REAL
DEAL ABOUT PERSONAL STYLE.
Jenascia: I'VE BEEN HAVING
TROUBLE DRESSING MYSELF LATELY
AS "MYSELF."
Shandi: I'VE GOT THIS, LIKE,
TOMBOYISH,
"I WANNA WEAR MY
TENNIS SHOES, "
"WHATEVER'S COMFORTABLE TO ME"
LOOK.
Catie: I'M STILL TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT MY PERSONAL STYLE.
Betsey: SO WHAT YOU'RE
GONNA DO IS,
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
WEAR YOUR OWN CLOTHES.
YOU'VE GOT TEN MINUTES
TO RUMMAGE AROUND
IN EVERYBODY ELSE'S CLOSETS.
I WAS LOOKING FOR THEIR BODY
LANGUAGE
AND THEIR HEART AND
SOUL AND SPIRIT.
HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH MAKEUP,
HAIR, CLOTHES OR SHOES.
HAS TO DO WITH
THE PERSON.
April: BETSEY'S TRYING
TO SEE
IF OUR PERSONAL STYLES
CAN RADIATE SO BRIGHT
THAT IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT KIND OF CLOTHES
WE'RE WEARING.
Betsey: I DO HAVE TO
PICK ONE WINNER.
THE BIG PRIZE TO THE CONTEST IS
A FABULOUS, FABULOUS DINNER
OUT IN NEW YORK CITY WITH SOME
FABULOUS,
FABULOUS GUEST.
READY, SET, GO!
Sara: WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH
EVERYBODY'S CLOTHES,
PICK OUT AN OUTFIT
THAT REPRESENTS US
WITHIN TEN MINUTES.
ME AND APRIL HAVE ALREADY
ESTABLISHED SHE'S GONNA TAKE
SOME OF MY CLOTHES,
AND I'M GONNA WEAR
HER BOOTS.
Yoanna: MERCEDES HAD A
CUTE LITTLE COQUETTE SKIRT
THAT I THOUGHT WOULD BE
REALLY CUTE AND PROBABLY
FLIRTY TO WALK IN.
Betsey: FIVE MINUTES AND
COUNTING!
Xiomara: I NEED
ANOTHER SKIRT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SKIRTS?
I WAS, LIKE, YO,
GIVE ME A SKIRT!
Camille: DO YOU HAVE ANY
ACCESSORIES?
Xiomara: AND THEN CAMILLE GOES,
"WELL,
LET ME BORROW YOUR
JEWELRY ."
AND THIS IS, UM,
WHAT I HAVE.
SO I GIVE HER
MY JEWELRY
IN HER HAND,
EVERYTHING--
MY WATCH, MY LEATHER CUFF AND MY
BEAUTIFUL, BEAUTIFUL
INDIAN EARRINGS.
Camille: I NEED A PAIR OF SHOES.
THE EARRINGS THAT SHE GAVE ME
AND, LIKE, THE JEWELRY SHE
GAVE ME DID NOT GO
WITH THAT PRETTY
PINK DRESS,
SO I TOOK IT.
I WENT TO THE BATHROOM,
AND I PUT IT ON THE COUNTER.
Betsey: THREE,
TWO, ONE.
GO SEE TIME!
WHOO!
OKAY, SARA
HAS TO START.
♪♪♪
Betsey: WHOO! EXCELLENTE!
WOW. SARA COULD
HAVE DONE
MY LAST RUNWAY SHOW.
XIOMARA.
ALL RIGHT!
(applause)
Betsey: THERE'S A TINY BIT
OF CONFUSION.
YOU WANT TO BE GLAMOROUS
BEAUTY, BUT I'D SAY
THE MORE HIP-HOP STYLE
IS YOU.
CAMILLE.
ALL RIGHT.
IT LOOKS ROUGH NOW.
YOU JUST NEED THAT POLISHING.
APRIL.
WHOO! OKAY!
GO, APRIL!
YOANNA.
ALL RIGHT.
OH, MY GOD! WHOO!
I MEAN,
YOU'RE ALL KNOCKING
ME OUT HERE.
Mercedes: I DON'T
FELL WELL,
BUT I'M TRYING
TO BE STRONG,
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO LET NO
ONE KNOW.
Betsey: MERCEDES.
WOW.
MISS SMILEY, FRIENDLY
PERSONALITY ON THE RUNWAY,
AND THAT WILL BE
YOUR STRENGTH.
JENASCIA.
♪♪♪
Betsey: HMM.
I'M NOT ONE OF THESE WHERE
UNLESS YOU'RE 6 FEET,
I CAN'T WORK
WITH YOU.
I THINK
YOU'RE ALMOST THERE.
JUST SIX MONTHS OF MODELING
SCHOOL,
WALKIN', ALL THAT JUNK.
Jenascia: SHE SAID I NEEDED SIX
MONTHS OF MODELING SCHOOL.
(record needle scratches)
Betsey: CATIE.
♪♪♪
Betsey: IT DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
OF THE REAL YOU YET,
CATIE.
Catie: OKAY.
Betsey: YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
WHO IS THAT,
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT THE
STYLE AND THE WALK,
BUT WE HAVEN'T FOUND CATIE
IN THE MIDDLE OF IT YET.
SHANDI.
Betsey: DON'T TRY TO
BE THE SEXPOT
THAT THE OTHER
GIRLS ARE DOING.
YOUR STRENGTH IS THAT
YOU'RE NOT THAT.
WHEW.
I HAVE TO DECIDE
WHO'S GONNA WIN.
SHANDI IS OUR WINNER.
Women: AW!
Shandi: YOU'RE KIDDING!
SHE'S LIKE, "THIS
IS OUR WINNER, "
AND, LIKE, ALL
THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE, LIKE, "AW, SHANDI."
I GET THAT A LOT
FROM THE GIRLS.
Betsey: I SEE A POTENTIAL IN
SHANDI THAT JUST NEEDS
A LITTLE TWEAKING.
BECAUSE EVEN THROUGH
THE HEELS
AND THROUGH THE DRESS,
YOU COULDN'T COVER UP
YOUR PERSONAL STYLE.
YOU GET TO
TAKE TWO GIRLFRIENDS
TO DINNER,
AND THEN YOU'LL MEET
YOUR SURPRISE MYSTERY GUEST.
Shandi: YOU AND YOU.
Xiomara: WHOO!
Betsey: OKAY!
Shandi: TODAY I GOT A
LOT OF ENCOURAGEMENT.
KIND OF HELPED ME
JUST TO DRIVE
AND JUST KEEP GOING
NO MATTER WHAT.
I'M NOT EVER GOING BACK TO
WALGREENS.
Yoanna: CAN WE SEE YOUR-- DO
YOUR CARTWHEEL!
Xiomara: YES.
(cheers and applause)
Betsey: THIS IS IT.
Women: WHOO!
♪♪♪
Xiomara: CAMILLE,
MY EARRING IS BROKEN, AND I-- I
MEAN, I CAN'T REPLACE IT.
Camille: WHEN IT WAS OVER,
XIOMARA CAME UP TO ME
AND WAS, LIKE, "CAMILLE, YOU
BROKE MY EARRING! "
I'M, LIKE... (sighs)
LIKE, "THIS IS ALL I FRICKIN'
NEED RIGHT NOW ."
MY GIRLFRIEND'S A JEWELRY
DESIGNER.
IT CAN BE FIXED, OKAY?
I'LL FIX IT
FOR YOU.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
Xiomara: SHE GAVE 'EM TO ME
BROKEN AND DIDN'T
TELL ME.
Sara: IS SHE POSITIVE?
Xiomara: NO.
WHY WOULD YOU JUST NOT JUST TELL
ME, "I'M SORRY
I BROKE YOUR EARRINGS.
I'M GONNA
GO FIX 'EM"?
Camille: SHE GAVE IT TO ME.
IT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY,
AND I'LL FIX IT,
BUT YOU'RE JUST GONNA
HAVE TO WAIT.
OKAY, SO NOW I HAVE TO
FIX THIS GIRL'S EARRING,
WHICH I WAS JUST,
LIKE, PFFT.
♪♪♪
(phone ringing)
Mercedes' mother: Hello?
Mercedes: HI, MOM.
HOW ARE YOU?
Mercedes' mother: You okay?
Mercedes: MY HAIR IS CONTINUING
TO FALL OUT...
LIKE, A LOT.
IT'S A LOT OF STRESS,
AND WHEN YOU
HAVE LUPUS,
YOU CAN'T STRESS OUT,
AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO DO
IN THIS HOUSE,
BECAUSE IT'S
VERY STRESSFUL.
PLEASE TELL ME--
IT'S COMING OUT,
AND I'M SCARED.
Mercedes' mother: Okay.
Don't be scared, okay?
Don't worry, okay?
Try not to stress out.
It's not good, okay?
Honey?
Mercedes: I HEARD YOU.
I'M SORRY.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO FEEL BAD
'CAUSE YOU CAN'T DO ANYTHING.
I'M JUST TRYING
TO JUST, LIKE,
KEEP ON
PUSHING MYSELF
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
IT'S NOT
THAT BAD--LUPUS.
I'M, LIKE, LIVING,
AND I'M OKAY.
I GET TIRED
OCCASIONALLY.
I'M HERE, AND I'M GONNA
DO WHAT I CAN
TO MAKE IT TO THE TOP.
♪♪♪
Shandi: THERE'S
A LIMO OUTSIDE.
I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S FOR US,
BUT IT SURE
IS PARKED
RIGHT IN FRONT.
Yoanna: SO I'M GOING WITH
SHANDI AND XIOMARA--
WE'RE GETTING READY TO
GO OUT IN THE EVENING
WITH OUR MYSTERY GUEST.
WE HAVE NO
IDEA WHO'S COMING.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: WHAT'S UP, LADIES?
Xiomara: WOW!
Yoanna: HI, ADRIANNE.
OH, WOW!
OH, SHE WON LAST TIME.
OUR GUEST IS LAST
YEAR'S WINNER OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL"--
ADRIANNE.
♪♪♪
Adrianne: I'M, LIKE,
BUSY EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I JUST DID A CHRISTOPHER
DEAN RUNWAY SHOW.
I'M BLINGED OUT TO DEATH
BECAUSE OF SIRENA DIAMONDS.
I'M A DIAMOND
SPOKESMODEL.
GOT REVLON ON MY BACKBURNER.
LIKE, I'M ACTUALLY LIVING
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
TO ONE OF YOU.
Yoanna: SO EXCITING!
Yoanna: HERE WE GO, GIRLS.
Xiomara: WE GO TO SOME
FRENCH RESTAURANT
IN THE UPPER WEST
SIDE.
Shandi: AND WE HAVE THE V
.I .P. ROOM
ALL TO OURSELVES.
(champagne cork pops)
Shandi: WHOO!
Adrianne: WHOO!
WHO DO YOU GUYS WANT TO BE
ELIMINATED NEXT?
Shandi: CAMILLE.
Yoanna: CAMILLE.
Xiomara: CAMILLE.
THE BITCH BROKE
MY EARRINGS.
SHE BROKE MY EARRINGS.
Adrianne: I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND
WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM.
I HAD A GIRL BORROW CLOTHES,
WORE 'EM OUT TO A CLUB.
SPILLED...
ALL OVER 'EM.
RUINED, LIKE,
CHRISTIAN DIOR GLASSES
AND STUFF,
AND THAT'S WHAT
YOU GOTTA DEAL WITH
IN THE REAL WORLD.
THESE BITCHES DON'T CARE.
Xiomara: OKAY, I'M GONNA
DO A FRICKIN'
UH, DEMONSTRATION OF...
Adrianne: IMPERSONATION.
Xiomara: CATIE--WHATEVER.
CATIE WALKS UP--YOU KNOW, SHE
HAS THIS LITTLE WALK
LIKE A LITTLE
PRINCESS.
Yoanna: OH, YEAH,
SHE GOES LIKE...
Xiomara: SHE'S LIKE, READY?
THIS IS THE SAME GIRL WHO CRIED
ABOUT BEING CALLED A HO.
Jenascia: OKAY,
SOMEONE DO XIOMARA.
April: GO, CATIE.
Sara: (laughs)
WHY ARE YOU SO GOOD
AT THIS?!
April: WAIT, I GOTTA SEE THE
FACE. WAIT, I GOTTA
SEE THE FACE.
DO IT AGAIN.
Catie: CAN ANYONE
DO YOANNA?
Mercedes: OH, THIS IS HER.
April: YEAH!
WHO ARE WE DOING?
Sara: CAMILLE.
Catie: YOU'LL KNOW.
(laughter and applause)
♪♪♪
Adrianne: MY DIAMOND CAMPAIGN IS
DONE COMPLETELY NUDE,
YOU KNOW, IN A POOL, LIKE...
IT'S SO...
OH, SO NICE.
SO NICE.
Yoanna: OH, WOW.
Adrianne: THEY WERE LIKE, "OKAY,
HONEY,
IT'S GONNA BE A
LONG DAY.
WE'RE REAL SORRY."
I'M LIKE, "LONG DAY?
I'M GONNA BE NAKED
IN A POOL
COVERED IN DIAMONDS!
WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT, LONG DAY? "
Yoanna: IT'S LUXURY.
Adrianne: WELL, YOU GUYS HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY OF A LIFETIME.
DON'T SCREW
THIS UP.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: WE GOT MAIL!
Camille: WHAT'S IT SAY?
READ IT.
Jenascia: "TELL ALL TABLOIDS,
PUSHY PAPARAZZI
AND FANATICAL FANS.
TOMORROW YOU'LL BE
SHOCKED AND AMAZED
BY THE STARS YOU'LL MEET.
BE READY AT 6: 30 IN
THE MORNING ."
Mercedes: OH, CRAP.
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO WEAR.
♪♪♪
Jay: GOOD MORNING, GIRLS.
Women: GOOD MORNING.
Jay: YOU KNOW, AS
A TOP MODEL,
YOU GUYS NEED TO LEARN HOW
TO TAKE ON THE PERSONA
OF SOMEONE ELSE.
SO TODAY,
WE'RE GONNA TURN YOU GIRLS INTO
SOME OF THE WORLD'S
MOST FAMOUS CELEBRITIES.
Jenascia: OOH, NICE.
Jay: ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PEOPLE
ON TODAY'S SHOOT IS YOUR
PHOTOGRAPHER--
ANDREW ECCLES.
TELL THE GIRLS SOME OF THE
CELEBRITIES YOU WORK WITH.
Andrew: SOME OF MY FAVORITES TO
PHOTOGRAPH ARE PROBABLY TYRA,
BROOKE SHIELDS, JOHN TRAVOLTA.
I'VE PHOTOGRAPHED ALL SORTS OF
PEOPLE.
Jay: CATIE, YOU ARE
GOING TO BE
MARILYN MONROE.
Catie: WHOO!
Andrew: MERCEDES, YOU'RE
GONNA BE BILLIE HOLIDAY.
Jay: APRIL,
CATHERINE ZETA-JONES.
April: I LOVE HER!
OH, MY GOSH.
Andrew: SHANDI,
YOU'RE GONNA
BE NICOLE KIDMAN.
Shandi: OH!
Jay: SARA, YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ANGELINA JOLIE.
Sara: OH, MY GOD.
Andrew: CAMILLE,
YOU'RE GONNA BE DIANA ROSS.
JENASCIA, YOU'RE GONNA
BE SALMA HAYEK.
Jenascia: SWEET.
Jay: YOANNA,
AUDREY HEPBURN.
Shandi: OH!
Jay: XIOMARA,
WHO ELSE COULD YOU BE
BUT GRACE JONES?
Xiomara: OKAY.
JAY JUST TOLD
ME THAT I'M BEING
MADE OVER TO BE GRACE JONES.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE
I LOOK LIKE HER.
I SAID, "IS THIS WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO ME?
WHY?"
SO ALL THESE THOUGHTS WERE
COMING IN MY HEAD, LIKE,
"THIS IS NOT GONNA BE
GOOD ."
Tyra: WHERE ARE THEY?
WHERE ARE THEY?
LET ME EXPLAIN SOMETHING
TO YOU.
Xiomara: YEAH.
Tyra: GRACE REPRESENTS A FASHION
ICON.
THAT'S SOMEBODY
THAT JANICE
USED TO WORK WITH.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
AND YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE, LIKE,
THE BIGGEST TRANSFORMATION
BECAUSE YOU
DON'T LOOK LIKE HER.
♪♪♪
Xiomara: JAY STARTED ME
OFF BY AIRBRUSHING ME.
IT WAS LIKE
A PERSONAL PROJECT
TO HIM, TURNING
ME INTO GRACE.
♪♪♪
Jay: ARE YOU
FEELIN' IT?
Yoanna: I'M FEELING IT.
Andrew: NICE.
Yoanna: I FEEL LIKE AUDREY
HEPBURN.
SHE'S ONE OF MY FAVORITE MOVIE
STARS OF ALL TIME.
Andrew: THAT LOOKS GREAT.
GOOD.
Jenascia: I THINK THEY MIGHT
HAVE PICKED SALMA FOR ME
BECAUSE SHE'S
SHORT
AND I'M SHORT.
BUT SHE'S DEFINITELY
GOT THE--
THE "T" AS FAR AS THE
"T" AND "A" GOES.
Andrew: SALMA'S GOT A VERY
CURVACEOUS LITTLE BODY,
SO YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO...
Jenascia: BA-BAM.
Andrew: JENASCIA HAD A DIFFICULT
CHALLENGE.
SALMA'S CONFIDENCE--
IT'S NOT THE EASIEST THING TO
FIND THAT.
TRY A LITTLE LEAN
OUT INTO THE CAMERA.
Tyra: JENASCIA,
THE LESS TEETH YOU SHOW,
THE MORE YOU LOOK
LIKE SALMA HAYEK.
Jenascia: DO THIS.
DO THIS.
OH, OH, OH, OH.
WHAT, WHAT?
Andrew: IT'S A 2-WAY STREET.
IT'S NOT FOR ME TO RUN
ALL THE WAY OVER THERE
AND GRAB
EVERYTHING FROM YOU.
GOOD.
Jenascia: YOU LIKE THAT, HUH?
YOU WANT SOME?
I GOT SOME MORE.
Andrew: SHE PROBABLY
HASN'T BEEN IN FRONT OF
THE CAMERA VERY OFTEN.
SHE'S GONNA HAVE TO WORK VERY
HARD FROM THIS POINT ON.
♪♪♪
Andrew: HERE WE GO, SARA.
TOUGHER.
THE KEY TO PORTRAYING ANGELINA
IS FINDING THAT
REALLY RAW SEXUALITY.
Tyra: LIKE,
DON'T BE AFRAID.
SEE, LIKE THAT.
SO YOU CAN GET THAT MUSCLE
AND ALL THAT STUFF
IN THERE.
THERE YOU GO.
Andrew: SARA--
I SORT OF SENSED THAT SHE'S
HOLDING BACK JUST A BIT.
Tyra: CAN YOU DO MORE SINISTER,
SARA?
SQUINT THE EYES.
SQUINT LIKE YOU'RE MAD.
Michael: WITH THE HAIR
AND THE BLUE EYES
AND THE DIAMOND EARRINGS,
AND YOU'LL BE LIKE THE
GLAMOROUS MARILYN.
Mercedes: TODAY
I'M REALLY SICK.
I JUST FEEL LIKE
I'M GONNA FAINT.
I'M JUST REALLY TIRED,
BUT I'M TRYING TO HIDE IT.
Xiomara: GRACE JONES--
SHE'S LIKE 20
THOUSAND SHADES
DARKER THAN ME.
I WAS LIKE,
"I DON'T KNOW
HOW THIS IS GONNA WORK."
Andrew: GOOD.
Tyra: SHANDI,
INHALE A LITTLE.
Andrew: NICE. HOW'S THAT?
Jay: SHANDI,
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
Andrew: ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
GREAT! GOOD!
Tyra: OH,
THIS IS SO DIANA ROSS!
Camille: DIANA ROSS--
SHE'S DEFINITELY
A STRONG DIVA,
AND I SEE MYSELF
IN THE SAME LIGHT.
Andrew: I'M CONVINCED.
Shandi: WHOA.
Xiomara: I KNOW.
Shandi: YOU LOOK CRAZY.
IT'S AWESOME.
XIOMARA'S WORRIED.
LIKE, I KNOW
THAT XIOMARA
PROBABLY WANTED TO BE, LIKE,
A MORE GLAMOROUS PERSON
BUT WHAT I THINK
OF GRACE JONES,
SHE SCARES
THE CRAP OUTTA ME.
Tyra: ARE WE READY, CATHERINE?
COME ON, DARLING.
Andrew: THIS WAY JUST
A LITTLE BIT, APRIL.
GOOD.
BEAUTIFUL.
APRIL--SHE SEEMS TO BE
THAT UNIQUE FIND
THAT TURNS UP NOW
AND AGAIN.
Catie: THIS PHOTO SHOOT,
I REALLY NEED TO
UP MY GAME
TO MAKE SURE I STAY HERE.
Andrew: GOOD.
TURN BACK TO ME.
Tyra: OH, YEAH.
PUT YOUR ARMS
BACK, 'CAUSE
YOU'RE
COVERING YOUR BREASTS.
STRETCH YOU LEGS OUT
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
Andrew: NICE.
Tyra: THE BOOTY'S
NOT OUT,
THOUGH.
STICK THE BOOTY.
YOU'RE DOING IT
LIKE THIS,
SO YOU'RE NOT REALLY
GETTING ANYWHERE.
IF YOU GO WAY BACK,
THEN YOU'RE LIKE THIS.
Catie: YEAH.
I REALLY WAS TRYING
TO BE STRONG
DURING THIS WHOLE
PHOTO SHOOT.
Andrew: THANK YOU, MY DEAR.
Mercedes: BE STRONG...
Xiomara: STRONG.
Mercedes: LIKE, YOU KNOW?
Xiomara: AT FIRST,
I WAS REALLY SCARED.
I'M LIKE, "I HOPE I COME OFF
LOOKING LIKE HER ."
Andrew: ALL RIGHT, DARLIN',
HERE WE GO, GOOD.
THE LEGS LIKE
THAT ARE GOOD,
BUT THEN MAYBE
THE UPPER BODY IS
STILL SORT OF STRAIGHT,
TOUGH.
YEAH, GOOD.
Tyra: OPEN YOUR LEGS
MORE, XIOMARA.
NO, NO.
Andrew: GREAT.
I TELL YOU,
THIS IS LIKE
GOING BACK IN TIME.
Tyra: TA-DA!
Andrew: GOOD.
Jay: JUST REAL.
GO FOR IT.
Tyra: GORGEOUS!
Xiomara: I DIDN'T THINK
I LOOKED LIKE HER,
BUT NOW I KNOW I DO.
Tyra: WE GOT IT!
Andrew: YOU'RE DONE.
Mercedes: THIS PHOTO
IS SO IMPORTANT TO ME
BECAUSE MY SECOND AND
THIRD WERE IFFY.
Andrew: JUST SORT OF CUP
IT WITH YOUR HAND.
YEAH, GOOD.
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
LET ME JUST HAVE
A LOOK AT THIS.
WAIT FOR ONE SECOND.
MERCEDES SEEMED
NERVOUS.
I DETECTED THAT SHE WAS EVEN
SHAKING JUST A LITTLE BIT.
Mercedes: I WAS NERVOUS.
BECAUSE I JUST DIDN'T
KNOW IF I CAN CAPTURE
BILLIE HOLIDAY'S
ESSENCE.
Tyra: SWELL UP WITH THE--
LIKE, THE SEXINESS,
LIKE THIS.
LIKE...
YOU CAN JUST...
(exhales deeply)
Andrew: GOOD.
Tyra: THERE YOU GO.
Jay: MERCEDES IS
JUST EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED.
Tyra: YEAH.
Andrew: NICE.
GOOD.
Jay: SHE'S STUNNING.
Andrew: GOT IT.
EXCELLENT.
WELL DONE.
Mercedes: I PRAY TO GOD.
EVERY TIME, I ASK HIM TO PUT A
LITTLE OOMPH IN FOR ME.
♪♪♪
Jenascia: I GOTTA GET OVER THIS
WHOLE SHORT COMPLEX.
POSSIBLY I DON'T
WANT THIS ENOUGH.
THIS LOOKS LIKE A LOTTA, LOTTA
HARD WORK.
Betsey: JUST SIX MONTHS OF
MODELING SCHOOL,
WALKIN', ALL THAT JUNK.
Jenascia: I'M KINDA SCARED.
Catie: THE PAST
THREE DAYS
HAVE BEEN THE WORST
DAYS OF MY LIFE.
I REALLY JUST WANT TO
GO HOME.
I'M AT A BREAKING POINT,
AND I CALLED MY
BOYFRIEND JUSTIN
AND TELL HIM, YOU KNOW,
SCREW IT.
I THOUGHT I WAS GONNA HAVE
THIS AMAZING
LIFE EXPERIENCE
AND JUST BE--LIVE TO TELL,
YOU KNOW,
TELL ABOUT IT
AND ALL THIS STUFF.
NO.
Justin: You sound like
you just want to quit,
and I don't like hearing that
in your voice.
My girlfriend's not a quitter.
Catie: I WANT THIS SO BADLY
THAT I'M ALMOST
CHANGING MYSELF,
AND THAT'S NOT HOW
I'M GONNA
GET TO THE TOP.
♪♪♪
Xiomara: WHO'S IT GONNA BE,
YOU GUYS?
IT'S ELIMINATION DAY.
I'M NERVOUS TO
SEE MY PICTURE.
Catie: I AM DEFINITELY
NERVOUS THAT THOSE ROUGH DAYS
THAT I DID HAVE
ARE GONNA
AFFECT ME,
AND THEY
AREN'T GONNA THINK
I'M STRONG ENOUGH FOR THIS.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
Women: HI!
Tyra: YOU GUYS LOOK SO NICE.
IT'S LIKE
SEXIFIED CATHOLIC SCHOOL.
YOU GUYS HAD A REALLY BUSY WEEK.
YOU LEARNED ALL
ABOUT PERSONAL STYLE,
AND YOU GOT TO
IMPERSONATE A FAMOUS PERSON
ON YOUR PHOTO SHOOT.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT
MY PICTURE
RIGHT HERE,
THIS IS MARIAH CAREY
AND LIL' KIM'S BABY.
WE HAD A LOT OF FUN
WITH THAT.
AND OF COURSE, WE HAVE
OUR PANEL OF CRAZY JUDGES.
WE HAVE JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS A
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR
AND THE FIRST SUPERMODEL,
SO SHE SAYS.
AND ERIC NICHOLSON,
SENIOR FASHION EDITOR
AT "JANE" MAGAZINE.
NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
OUR GUEST JUDGE,
THE BEAUTIFUL
BETSEY JOHNSON.
ALL RIGHT, HERE
ARE THE PRIZES.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
A CONTRACT WITH IMG,
WHICH IS THE NUMBER ONE
MODELING MANAGEMENT FIRM
IN THE WORLD,
A SPREAD IN "JANE" MAGAZINE
AND A COSMETICS CAMPAIGN
WITH SEPHORA.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AND BETSEY'S GOING TO
ADMINISTER YOUR TEST.
Betsey: YOU'RE GOING TO BE
TESTED ON
YOUR ABILITY
TO ACCESSORIZE
YOUR LITTLE BLACK DRESS.
YOU ALL HAVE THE
SAME STUFF
IN YOUR PILE.
PICK OUT WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA PUT ON.
SHOW ME YOUR STYLE,
BUT MAKE YOURSELF LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE GOING OUT ON THE TOWN
IN NEW YORK CITY.
BE READY AND FINISHED IN 60
SECONDS.
READY?
SET... GO!
Janice: ACCESSORIZE, GIRLS!
♪ ACCESSORIZE ♪♪
♪♪♪
Betsey: FIVE...
FOUR...
THREE...
TWO...
ONE...
DONE!
Tyra: OKAY, YOANNA.
Yoanna: WELL,
I WANTED TO
KEEP IT SIMPLE
AND JUST HAVE MY PEARLS
AND MY
SIMPLE BLACK DRESS.
Tyra: I THINK IT WORKS.
Janice: YOU COULD BE GOING OUT
TO DINNER IN LONDON,
PARIS OR NEW YORK.
Yoanna: THANK YOU.
Tyra: THIS WAS YOUR
BEST SHOT
ON YOUR IMPERSONATION DAY.
Eric: AW.
Janice: AUDREY HEPBURN!
Nigel: I THINK YOUR EYES
LOOK FANTASTIC.
Betsey: YEAH, BOOM!
Tyra: OKAY, APRIL.
Janice: YOU'RE LOOKIN'
A LITTLE KMART TO ME.
Eric: THE DRESS LOOKS
BETTER WITHOUT THE SCARF.
Janice: WITHOUT.
THAT LOOKS
BETTER LIKE THAT.
Tyra: AND HERE'S YOUR
BEST SHOT.
Eric: CHRISTINA
AGUILERA?
Tyra: THAT'S CATHERINE
ZETA-JONES.
Eric: IT IS CATHERINE.
Janice: THAT'S CATHERINE
ZETA-JONES?
Nigel: THE BEST I'VE SEEN.
YOUR EYES LOOK FANTASTIC.
Tyra: THE OBVIOUS THING FOR YOU
WOULD, OF COURSE,
TO HAVE BEEN WHO?
April: LUCY LIU OR
KELLY HU.
Tyra: LUCY LIU, BUT
I WANTED
TO CHALLENGE
YOU AND PUSH YOU.
I FEEL LIKE
CATHERINE ZETA-JONES
MIGHT HAVE A
LITTLE SOMETHIN',
SOMETHIN' IN
HER, TOO.
MERCEDES, COME ON DOWN.
Mercedes: I CHOSE THE
PEARLS AND THE PURSE
FOR A CLASSIC LOOK
AND THEN THE
SCARF FOR FUN.
Janice: IT'S BAD PROM,
BABY.
Betsey: CAN YOU TAKE
IT ALL OFF?
Janice: TAKE THE SCARF TO TIE
YOUR BOYFRIEND UP WITH.
Tyra: TAKE YOUR
HAIR DOWN
AND GO BACK
TO YOUR STATION,
AND REALLY THINK
ABOUT IT
THIS TIME.
LOOK AT THAT!
Eric: GOT IT.
Tyra: THAT'S GORGEOUS!
WE HAVE YOUR PICTURE.
Janice: LADY SINGS
THE BLUES.
Eric: YEAH, BILLIE HOLIDAY.
Tyra: THE GOOD THING
ABOUT YOU IS THAT YOU GAVE
LITTLE CHANGES WITH
EACH FRAME.
IT'S, LIKE, INSTINCTUAL FOR YOU.
OKAY, UP NEXT WE HAVE SHANDI.
Shandi: I CHOSE THE SCARF.
I JUST WANNA ADD
A LITTLE BIT OF TEXTURE
TO THE DRESS.
Janice: I ALWAYS THINK THAT
MODELS, WHEN THEY TIE
THINGS AROUND THEIR WAISTS--
THEY'RE JUST HIDING
A LARGE ASS.
Tyra: I'D SAY TAKE OFF THAT
PURSE.
Janice: AND THE
SEÑORITA SHAWL.
Tyra: AND THE SHAWL.
Janice: HASTA LA VISTA,
BABY.
Tyra: WHY DON'T YOU GO GRAB THAT
PEARL BRACELET
AND TAKE THAT RING OFF?
Janice: GRAB THE PEARLS.
GOOD CHOICE, T.
Tyra: IT'S LIKE "ALICE IN
WONDERLAND" NOW...
ON PARK AVENUE.
AND THIS IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
WHO'S THAT?
Eric: NICOLE KIDMAN.
Tyra: YES.
Nigel: WE KNOW WHO YOU
WERE MEANT TO BE,
BUT IT LOOKS A
LITTLE STIFF.
Tyra: SARA.
Janice: IT'S KIND
OF A MESSY LOOK.
Tyra: TAKE YOUR HAT OFF.
TAKE THE HAIR DOWN.
YOU JUST NEED
A HOOP EARRING NOW.
Nigel: THAT'S VERY
SOPHIA LOREN.
Tyra: YEAH! LOOK AT THAT!
Janice: (clapping)
VOILà.
A MODEL.
Tyra: MODEL.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Eric: OH, WOW.
Nigel: ANGELINA JOLIE.
Janice: WHERE'S
YOUR VIAL
OF BILLY
BOB THORNTON'S BLOOD?
Eric: I THINK YOU DEFINITELY
GOT HER ATTITUDE.
Tyra: YOUR EYES, LIKE,
YOU HAD A
HARD TIME PUTTING
INTENSITY INTO THEM.
CAMILLE.
Camille: I DECIDED TO USE
THIS SILVER CHAIN AND, UM, I
LIKE IT 'CAUSE IT
ACCENTS MY NECK,
AND I CHOSE THE RING 'CAUSE
THE SHAPES ARE CIRCLES.
AS YOU SEE,
CIRCLES HERE.
Eric: IT WOULD SHOW A LITTLE
BIT MORE CONFIDENCE,
MAYBE, IF YOU HAD SAID,
"I CHOSE THE NECKLACE
'CAUSE I LOVED IT ."
Camille: A SIMPLE NECKLACE.
LIKE, A LOT OF THOUGHT
WENT INTO THIS,
EVEN HOW THE CIRCLES--
Eric: ALL I'M SAYING IS THAT
IT'S NOT BRAIN SURGERY,
YOU KNOW?
DON'T MAKE IT INTO BRAIN
SURGERY.
Camille: I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING,
BUT I WANNA BE RIGHT.
Tyra: YOU HAD TO IMPERSONATE A
FAMOUS PERSON.
HERE WAS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: CALL ME MISS ROSS!
"ESSENCE," HERE WE COME.
Tyra: JENASCIA.
♪♪♪
Jenascia: I LOVE HATS,
AND THE BELT
BECAUSE I FELT
LIKE I NEEDED
SOMETHING TO GO
WITH THE HAT.
Nigel: YOU LOOK CONFUSED.
BRING UP
YOUR CONFIDENCE.
Janice: CAN YOU DO
ME A FAVOR AND REMOVE THE HAT?
Tyra: AND THE BELT.
Janice: AND THE BELT.
Tyra: CAN YOU TAKE OFF THE
EARRINGS?
Janice: YEAH, LOSE EVERYTHING.
THAT--YOU ARE SO ELEGANT.
Jenascia: I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO DO ELEGANT YET.
Janice: I WANNA SEE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND I DON'T WANNA SEE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP STREET MODEL.
Tyra: SO YOU HAD YOUR PHOTO
SHOOT,
AND HERE WAS YOUR BEST SHOT.
NICE.
Janice: SALMA HAYEK.
FINALLY I SEE A LITTLE MODEL
COMING FORWARD.
Tyra: CATIE.
Catie: I WANTED TO KEEP IT
REALLY SIMPLE, 'CAUSE I THINK
IT'S A GORGEOUS DRESS,
AND I DON'T WANNA
TAKE AWAY FROM IT.
Tyra: I LIKE
THE FACT THAT
YOU THOUGHT OF A
CERTAIN ERA,
YOU KNOW,
WITH THE WHOLE
MOD THING.
THIS IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU WERE MARILYN.
Janice: IT LOOKS LIKE A
BEAUTIFUL GUY HERE.
Eric: THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT IT
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT DRAG.
Tyra: I'VE BEEN
AROUND DRAG QUEENS, AND THEY
WISHED THEY LOOKED
LIKE THAT.
OKAY, XIOMARA.
Xiomara: I WANTED TO THINK
'70s WITH THE
HEAD SCARF, LIKE,
VERY, LIKE, MARY TYLER MOORE.
Eric: YOU'RE GUNS
N' ROSES,
THOUGH, NOT MARY TYLER MOORE.
Nigel: I'D LIKE TO LOSE THE
EARRINGS AND THE BAG.
Tyra: THE BELT
DOESN'T GO
WITH THE SCARF.
SEE, NOW THAT'S VERY-- OH, WHAT
IS THIS? "CARMEN"?
Eric: "GYPSY."
Tyra: "GYPSY."
"GYPSY," THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
Xiomara: THAT'S TOTALLY
MY STYLE.
THANK YOU.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Eric: OOH.
Janice: AAH!
Eric: GRACE JONES.
Tyra: CAN WE HAVE
A CLOSE-UP?
Eric: WOW.
Betsey: WHOA.
Eric: YOU LOOK LIKE
A NUBIAN
SPACE GODDESS.
Tyra: I GAVE IT TO
YOU BECAUSE I KNEW
THAT YOU COULD HANDLE IT.
Nigel: GRACE WOULD BE PROUD.
Tyra: OKAY. THANK YOU.
UM, YOANNA.
Nigel: YOANNA,
I THINK, IS
ONE OF THE
MOST BEAUTIFUL FACES
IN THE COMPETITION.
Janice: SHE LOOKS POSSESSED
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH,
LIKE A POSSESSED
AUDREY HEPBURN.
Tyra: SARA REALLY
KNOWS HOW
TO WORK HER BODY.
IT'S THE ONE NOTE
WITH THE FACE.
Janice: CAMILLE--
SHE NAILED DIANA ROSS, BUT I
HATED HER ATTITUDE TONIGHT.
Eric: SHE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT SHE
WAS TALKING ABOUT.
AN EMPTY BARREL MAKES
THE MOST NOISE.
Tyra: CAMILLE IS LIKE,
YOU KNOW, "I'M THE BADDEST BITCH
UP IN HERE ."
Eric: CAMILLE--
SHE BETTER BE CAREFUL.
Tyra: JENASCIA.
Nigel: I WANNA SEE
A MORE POSITIVE PERSON.
Janice: SHE'S STILL TOO
SHORT.
Tyra: I LIKE THAT
JENASCIA IS SHORT.
I THINK IT'S SPECIAL.
IT MAKES YOU
STAND OUT,
BUT YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU HAVE
THINGS THAT
ARE LACKING
NEXT TO THE OTHER GIRLS,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOMETHING EXTRA
SPECIAL,
AND I DON'T FEEL LIKE
SHE DOES.
SHANDI.
Betsey: I LIKED HER,
THE ODDNESS,
THE BLACK SHEEP.
Tyra: APRIL.
Eric: IN THIS PICTURE,
SHE COMES A LITTLE BIT LA TOYA
JACKSON.
Tyra: SHE SEEMS VERY
ANALYTICAL, UM,
AND LESS ROMANTIC.
MISS CATIE.
Eric: CATIE IS SO SORT OF
DEAD IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA.
Betsey: I DON'T THINK
SHE'S STRONG ENOUGH
TO, UM, CUT IT.
Tyra: MERCEDES.
Eric: WHAT'S SO
BEAUTIFUL
ABOUT THIS IS THAT
THERE'S SUCH INCREDIBLE
SORT OF SADNESS
IN HER EYES.
Tyra: I WASN'T HAPPY
WITH XIOMARA ON SET
WHEN SHE
FOUND OUT THAT
SHE WAS GONNA BE
GRACE JONES.
I FEEL LIKE, YOU KNOW,
ETHNIC WOMEN
NEVER WANNA BE DARKER.
NEVER.
THOUSANDS OF GIRLS
WANNA BE HERE,
AND YOU'RE TRIPPIN'
THAT
YOU'RE GONNA
BE GRACE JONES?
GRACE IS, LIKE, A FASHION ICON,
GORGEOUS, BEAUTIFUL,
BLACK WOMAN,
YOU KNOW?
Janice: OHH! THE BEST!
Tyra: AND I WAS JUST A LITTLE
INSULTED BY THAT.
NINE BEAUTIFUL LADIES STANDING
IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
EIGHT PICTURES
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE EIGHT PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE EIGHT OF YOU THAT
WILL STILL BE IN
THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
FIRST NAME I'M
GOING TO CALL--
MERCEDES.
LATELY, I'VE SEEN YOUR ENERGY IS
JUST NOT THE SAME
AS IT USED TO BE,
BUT I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE
THAT BUBBLY
PERSONALITY COME BACK.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN
THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
XIOMARA.
THIS IS ONE OF
THE FIERCEST PICTURES
IN THE BUNCH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Xiomara: THANK YOU.
Tyra: SHANDI.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOANNA.
SARA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
APRIL.
I STILL FEEL LIKE YOU'RE VERY
ANALYTICAL,
BUT I WANNA SEE THE SENSITIVE
AND BEAUTIFUL SIDE
OF YOU, TOO.
CONGRATULATIONS.
CAMILLE.
THIS PICTURE IS ABSOLUTELY
GORGEOUS.
I SEE CAMILLE,
AND I SEE
DIANA ROSS,
BUT ANOTHER THING
YOU HAVE
THAT DIANA
IS KNOWN FOR
IS A DIVA ATTITUDE,
AND THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL THING
ABOUT THE TOP MODELS THAT
AMERICA LOVES
IS BEING HUMBLE
AND BEING MODEST.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN
THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL JENASCIA AND
CATIE PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS THE
WOMAN THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
JENASCIA, YOUR SALMA
HAYEK RENDITION
WAS ABSOLUTELY
BEAUTIFUL,
BUT IF
YOU HAVE SOMETHING
A LITTLE BIT LESS
THAN OTHERS,
YOU GOTTA
OVERCOMPENSATE,
AND I FEEL LIKE
YOU LACK THAT.
CATIE,
YOUR MARILYN
MONROE RENDITION
WAS GORGEOUS,
BUT WE FEEL LIKE,
IS SHE STRONG ENOUGH
TO HANDLE
THIS BUSINESS
WHEN IT IS
CONSTANT CRITIQUE
AND CONSTANT REJECTION?
I'M LOOKING AT
ONE WOMAN'S PICTURE,
AND IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: CATIE.
YOU'RE STILL IN
THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
Tyra: BYE, JENASCIA.
Jenascia: THIS HOUSE IS TOTALLY
GONNA SUCK WITHOUT ME.
I NEVER THOUGHT THAT I WOULD GET
HERE,
SO I NEVER
THOUGHT ABOUT
WHAT I WOULD
DO AFTER THIS.
I AM GONNA GO BACK TO SLINGING
CHICKEN WINGS
AT HOOTERS
AND BACK TO
MY FRIENDS
AND JUST BEING
THE HAPPY PERSON
THAT I AM.
♪♪♪
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL"...
THE FLOODGATES
OPEN UP...
Sara: THIS IS HARD
AS HELL.
Man: DON'T PANIC.
Tyra: WHILE MERCEDES' SECRET
ILLNESS
BECOMES AN ISSUE.
JUST BE HONEST
AND SPEAK UP.
Mercedes: YOU KNOW, I'M JUST
TRYING TO STICK IN THERE.
♪♪♪